it's great to be joined today by Bryant
Welch who's a clinical psychologist and
author of the books state of confusion
political manipulation and the assault
on the American mind and I've so many
questions for you Brian but I guess
first just to introduce our audience to
the the sort of topic of your book and
the angle that you're taking here when
you say the assault on the American mind
what are you referring to I think most
of us now realize something is amiss in
America and I think people have a little
bit of a sense that it's something of a
psychological nature what I'm trying to
do in state of confusion is call
attention to the American mind how it
functions and why it's been functioning
so poorly and why it is a bigger problem
than Donald Trump
Donald Trump is more a symptom of the
problem but the real problem is with
what's happened to the American mind so
in state of confusion I'm trying to say
if we will pay more attention to the
mind there's a lot we can do still save
our country and if we don't things are
going to deteriorate I wrote the first
version of the book of 10 15 years ago
and if you look in the second version of
the book I document the deterioration
that's taken place during that time and
we don't have a lot of time left we've
got to start attending to the mind and
understanding that our mind is like any
other organ in our body our stomach or
heart or what have you
it's wondrous but it's also limited it's
affected by how we treat it and it
requires a certain amount of care if
it's to function effectively you talk in
sort of general terms about how when we
look at political events or political
decisions that are made by elected
officials there are often sort of
surface level political explanations for
some of these phenomena but there are
actually psychological reasons and
underpinnings that we should also be
paying attention to and one example
would be sort of the decision to go into
Iraq after 9/11 right a country that did
not actually have anything to do with
that attack
and we can come up with all sorts of
political explanations george w bush
wanted to finish the job his father
couldn't or it was actually about oil
and a convenient excuse or sort of
political explanations but you believe
that there's a psychological
underpinning to this that's not getting
the attention it should it's the way the
mind tries to differentiate what's
inside it from what's outside it after
9/11 the country was absolutely
terrified understandably and when our
mind is in that kind of terror when
we're filled with anxiety we try to find
some type of external explanation and
some type of cohesive way in which we
can do battle with the terror and so
after 9/11 our minds were very very
disrupted we were looking for some way
to organize that fear George Bush was
there offering us a solution and saying
look the problem is over in Iraq and
that's where the enemy is target your
fear over there and let's go address it
now today of course we've got an even
worse problem with paranoia in that
we've got a president who's actively
encouraging us to project our fears out
onto other people generally with
different colored skin but there are
people from Central America coming up
into this country trying to destroy us
which is pretty hard to believe and or
that it's the Muslim people of Muslim
faith who are trying to destroy America
and the threat so we project out onto
when we're afraid we don't like to
confront the fact that we don't
understand our fear and so we come up
with a ready-made simplistic solution to
it and I spend a lot of time in the book
explaining those mechanisms in the mind
and they really are quite interesting if
we're aware of those met
there's a lot we can do to control them
inside ourselves and to help one another
with it but if we don't if we're not
aware of those mechanisms were
vulnerable to them and someone comes
along politically and place to those
fears as Trump is now and we can do a
lot of damage to ourselves to our loved
ones into the whole world yeah there
seems to be quite a bit of overlap in
the sort of type of thinking that you're
suggesting people do in your book to
some of the work of Daniel Kahneman and
recognizing that there are certain
cognitive biases and heuristics that
better at play so for example if we
recognize that we are drawn to seemingly
simple neat and tidy explanations to
phenomena in the real world even if they
are not accurate that might enable us to
say hold on a second just because I'm
getting this nice simple solution from
Trump hey let's build a wall as an
example or hey let's stop Muslim
immigration to the US if we know that
sometimes we have this sort of bias
towards a coherent narrative we might be
able to stop ourselves and re-examine
more critically whether the facts
actually bear that out we've got going
for us in this problem and trying to
address it is that the very act of
awareness improves our functioning
awareness awareness awareness and what
the mind must do if it's to make us feel
comfortable is construct a reality out
of the chaotic world that surrounds us
when it has a hard time doing that it
gets very very anxious so a condiment
and others are saying is look that
creates a bias if you will in the
direction of validating what we think
and what we can think easily and when
people are struggling in that way they
become much less tolerant of people with
different points of view this country
has always had a wide range of different
perspectives and points of view but
we've been able to contain them and to
not be so threatened by other people's
point of view that we can't tolerate
and that we start to hate them so we are
always going to have these differences
we have but we don't have to be hating
one another and we can put our minds
together and come up with the best
solutions we're able to but right now
you know the government shut down we
can't do anything in terms of in terms
of listening to one another what do you
make of the success that the III don't
really want to say the right although
the right is a big perpetrator of this
but it's the elites who have been able
to convince Americans that they should
all favor policies that are
overwhelmingly favorable to those who
are already extraordinarily wealthy we
saw this in the 2010 midterms the first
midterms under President Barack Obama
the rise of the Tea Party movement of
movement supported overwhelmingly by
people who were not rich and never we're
going to be rich just statistically
supporting policy that is very good for
rich people what is happening
psychologically that that has been a
successful movement state of confusion
that's what I'm writing about you
couldn't have stated it more effectively
what if you look at how the mind
operates there are some dimensions to
the mind that are more vulnerable to
destabilization than others paranoia is
one I've talked about but sexual
perplexity and gender orientation gender
identity sexual orientation issues is
another envy and greed is the third
those three states of mind I call the
battleground states the reason people
are voting against their interest is
because these particularly vulnerable
states of mind are being triggered and
they serve as powerful distractions
against people being able to sort out
what's in their best interest so if you
can strike the mine in one of these
battleground states that is
discombobulating to the mind you begin
to own them because they're going to
focus on that if you're concerned that
people of different color are coming
into the country trying to take your
jobs committing crime
killing your children well that's going
to get your attention
the instability of the mind that creates
and that's what you attend to not the
fact that some some wealthy some wealthy
individual has put a hundred million
dollars into convincing you to be so
scared so that he or she can then run
off with all the money and ignore the
long-term best interest of the country
so that is what I'm talking about is how
does the mind get triggered in a way
that destabilizes it and makes it
irrational and that is our national
state of confusion what are the
techniques that are most effective for
people to sort of protect themselves or
be armed
figuratively against this sort of war on
the mind or propaganda war that is that
is being waged is it simply awareness of
these biases and tendencies or is more
required well let me let me say the way
I would always answer that is to say
awareness awareness awareness but I
think when we begin to understand what
awareness is we would no longer say
simply awareness is a remarkable
psychological process it is the process
that we have by which we do our awaring
that it's an activity it's a function of
the mind and when we are aware if we can
name it we containment and that's what
neuroscience is showing us and it is a
wonderful new thing that we're
discovering the brain and the mind are
remarkably malleable they recover but if
we can get people to focus on the
problem rather than activating these
three battleground states that I talked
about you look at what Donald Trump is
doing now of activating activating
activating and no one notices that
people are running off with with the
vault with all the money in the process
because they're so activated and that's
been going on long before Trump Trump is
just a symptom of the problem he is not
the cause of it
and if you look at what leaders have
done in the past in America take FDR
1932 things were very dire in this
country not just the economic crisis but
there was a rise in terms of racism and
and bigotry
there was flirtation with Nazism what
did Roosevelt did knew the first thing
that Roosevelt said to us after he
became president first inaugural address
first paragraph we have nothing to fear
but fear itself now what he was doing
with that was calling our attention
making ourselves aware of our inner
state of what was going on in our mind
and once he identified that he came up
with a series of solutions ways that we
could work together to address that fear
we didn't have to be paralyzed by it we
didn't have to be defeated by it and he
then led to a plan that dismantled the
Great Recession he took on Hitler and
Nazism and it was a result of being able
to identify what was going on inside
people's minds and then coming up with
solutions and we could have a leader
like that that could emerge in America
but we need it well that's what I was
going to ask and in the brief time we
have left on a psychological level of
appeal to the electorate it when you
look at 20/20 and you look at the
campaign of some Democrats still to be
determined
likely against Donald Trump what will
that nominee need in order to appeal to
voters in a way that could defeat Trump
that need his or her own view of reality
the mine is struggling the American mind
is struggling to support and develop and
congeal a sense of reality and what is
the reality that we're all going to buy
into it is it if you look at what was
successful about Obama it was that there
was this appeal to hope and what we
could become if you look at what was
successful about John Kennedy it
that with the sputnik fear and as scared
as we are all war with that there was a
lot that we could do there was a lot
that we could look at the fear and then
harness it in this country I think
everybody is terrified economically
we're the wealthiest country in the
history of the world and yet everyone
like 80% of the American pop American
people are living from paycheck to
paycheck in a world that's constantly
changing out from under them it's
terrifying and we need to come together
and put an end to that kind of economic
terror and the abyss that we all feel
were edgy ever closer to so in a sense I
mean is it is it rather than playing
point/counterpoint with Trump's view of
reality is it creating your own
alternative yes absolutely
yes when you go when you go point
counterpoint with Donald Trump you're
building up Donald Trump Donald Trump
was a genius at making himself the
center of attention he was running
against 16 far more qualified
conservative candidates in the
Republican primaries and he stole the
stage by being outrageous what we need
is our candidates who will outline their
view of reality where is America today
what is it we're afraid of and what do
we need to do to overcome it now there
are a lot of issues like that but we
basically it requires populism in a way
that makes us healthier rather than
populism that plays to our fears yes
left wing versus right wing populism is
actually something we've we've spoken
about extensively on the program
clinical psychologist Brian Welch who
has been speaking with us the book by
Bryant Welch is state of confusion
political manipulation and the assault
on the American mind Brian thank you so
much for talking to us today it's been a
pleasure